do you want me to do some testings or
we're loved yeah alright hey everybody
welcome to the free code camp 2018 Top
Contributors party in Dublin yeah we
have amazing people from all around
Europe in Africa thank you everybody for
coming out it's great and we're thrilled
to welcome you all and to celebrate your
many contributions to the freako camp
open source community and to your own
cities local developer communities so
many of you are so critical in helping
people in your communities realize that
they can become developers and giving
them actionable advice as to how they
can do that so I just want to give a big
round of applause for everybody here
yeah all right well we're gonna be
streaming for the next three hours or so
2 hours and 45 minutes
we started a little late thanks for your
patience everybody is tuning in and it
should be really exciting we'll talk
about a lot of exciting things before we
get started I have some very quick
announcements things that are coming up
very soon that I think everybody who's
interested in freako camp should know
first of all just like last year when
freako camp participated in hack tober
fest and hack tober fest is the month of
october it's a big push to get people to
contribute to open source last year free
code camps guide was the number one most
contributed to open source repo as part
of Oktoberfest
and since then the the repos gotten 707
thousand poll requests yeah so I'll be
completely candid it was a lot more than
we were ready for and we're still
closing all the way like we're back to
like October 25th we've been working
backward but if you made poor requests
back in October don't worry we're gonna
get to those soon and we are going to
get that all the way down we're working
very hard to do that and we're going to
make it much easier to contribute to
freako camp in October 2018 for the
Oktoberfest
so the way we're doing that is we're
taking a lot of the existing
repositories we've got learned we've got
a curriculum we've got the freako camp /
free cooking at the main repository and
then we've got the guide we're working
to unify these repos into a single
repository that will make it easier for
everybody to get the local freako camp
running and to put him on the spot I'd
like for Stuart to come up and say a few
quick words about that let's give it up
for Stuart Stuart Taylor he's he's from
right just three hours away from here
near Belfast oh yeah so the idea the
current situation of contra meant to
freak out camp is if you wanted to have
the curriculum app up and running and
that's really sorry yeah so the
curriculum app if you wanna the
curriculum at Moran and you want to
interact with this server locally you
have to have at least two Kahn prompts
open so the idea is we're going to have
just one command that will run the
curriculum up which is learned off we
come to org when you have the API server
in as well and you'll be able to once
again edit the curriculum and see the
changes live in your browser
yeah so hopefully they'll make it a lot
easier for everybody to contribute to
and we are looking forward to you pull
requests thank you so yes it will be
much easier and our efforts will be
focused on a single repository this act
over fest the core free code camp
repository which should simplify like
we'll have a single contributing MD file
that has instructions ideally we'll have
a single script that bootstraps your
local environment so that you've got
your database running and you've got
your npm install taken care of and so
you're not having to click back and
forth and input a whole bunch of
commands yourself so that way it will
just be much easier to to do the first
step to contributing to open source
which is cloning the repo and getting it
running locally so we're very excited
about that effort
a couple other announcements since you
are watching this on the YouTube channel
according to like the YouTube analytics
we looked at freako camp is now the
fastest growing programming YouTube
channel yeah and we're getting about
50,000 new subscribers a month so if if
you see it like a little subscribe
button and it's like red and it doesn't
it's not it should be gray and it should
say subscribed so just click it and it
should do that and you can turn them the
little belt thing too and that will
notify you in when we publish new videos
which is almost every day we've been
publishing comprehensive in-depth
tutorials on Java C++ we recently
published coming in anthology video by
Brianna who's here who flew in from
Berlin today and it it covers basically
how computers work how networks work how
how the internet works
it covers all that in a nice 25 minute
very concise video but we also have
videos that are you know eight nine
hours long
that go into depth and show you how to
build full projects and bootstrap
developer environments for you know
everything from c-sharp to java to no
js' and Ruby on Rails and things like
that so we're gonna continue to publish
incredible comprehensive substantial
tutorials all of which will be
completely free we're not showing any
commercials if you create compelling
videos about programming and you're
interested we would love to help more
people see your intent your videos so
just reach out to us and we can make
that happen but for us we want to put as
many amazing videos on YouTube as we can
so we're here in Dublin we're at I've
got a cool sign for it
the Huckle tree which is a really cool
hipster name and it has a hashtag I just
noticed that so this is a very cool
venue and they've been really cool and
cooperative when you have to wire money
from America and coordinate catering and
all that stuff through email it can be
challenging but I just want to do a
shout out to the whole tree for being
very helpful and having this beautiful
venue that has lots of Irish tea which
is like super caffeinated kind of
English breakfast tea that I've been
drinking all night to counter the jetlag
so we're gonna go in a big circle we've
got a lot of people here and everyone
can take a moment to introduce
themselves and where they're from and
what they do for the free Koch camp
community and the first person we're
gonna hear from is Timo aka systematic
hee hee has contributed so much to the
freako camp gun anyway I'll let you
introduce yourself thank you my name is
Steve oh I am from the Netherlands from
where da and and I've contributed a lot
to the free column guides and if we can
prove our story as well and I haven't
been contributing that much for the past
year but I hope to get back into it more
now I got an internship and then I got a
job and I had to get used to it I'm sure
and I am a developer for freako camp
everything I do every day is for free
cocoa I'm Ben I'm from just down the
road in Dublin I am one of the old
number six in the repo so I need to get
that pushed up again and again another
person who's got life in the bit in the
way but I'm hoping to get back on at
this year yeah hi everyone I'm Sam I
started by writing a couple of articles
and sent one to Quincy who I was just
asking for some advice he said that's
brilliant and actually stuck here on the
freako camp medium publication since
then I've written more and more articles
and trying to give tutorials to the kind
of people that want to get into writing
code and possibly taking it up as a
career hey guys I'm Jonathan and from
Belfast Northern Ireland and I haven't
been too active the last year but and
mostly tried contributing to the Kobus
and some of the guide as well so
hello my name's Pete I'm a data
scientist based in London and I write
and help edit the medium publication the
free code camp hi I'm Matt I'm a
software developer also in London and I
organized the London freaking meetups
hi I'm Gary and I wrote articles to the
pre-code comedian publications hi I'm
David Kopel from Czech Republic I live
in a part of it and I write articles to
freak out come publications many about
JavaScript and now in about reason ml so
definitely check out written ml I know
it's difficult renunciates and I'm
making YouTube videos from owners that
freaking help us publish some of my
videos I I'm Eva DS from Portugal I was
a civil engineering and in six months
I've rebooted my career and nowadays I'm
a real remote developer working from
Portugal to the Netherlands in react and
redux hi I'm Richard I'm from South
Africa Johannesburg I with others
organized meetups from Johannesburg and
I'm a software developer and thanks to
free code Cam's curriculum I have
managed to you know break into the
industry which I you know at the
beginning I thought was impossible to do
but yeah I'm very grateful to Quincy and
the team and meeting all of you guys
it's just been fantastic I'm learning a
lot and I continue to learn in my day to
day job and yeah I'm looking forward to
the rest of the evening
yay
hi I'm Brianna I have made some videos
for a free code cams YouTube channel I'm
from Kansas City originally but now live
in Berlin as much as I'm grateful to be
able to contribute to free code camp I
feel like as many people in this room
free code camp has really contributed to
me and to my life and I'm really
grateful for that hi I'm Andrea I'm a
student and my contributions to freak
attempt were mainly writing articles on
the medium publication and flooding the
guides repository of poor request hi I'm
Joan 4 from Portugal I started freaking
camp I changed my career and we decided
we did wardo to create a study group in
Portugal to help other students get
there hi good evening I'm Johnny from
Leeds I spend a lot of time helping out
beginners on the forum plus like help
with a coffee and code we regulate out
there in Leeds [ __ ] Leeds England ok
thank you
hi my name is Robert I'm from Norway
live in Austria I started the local free
coke and Vienna group in Austria 3 years
ago there was nothing so I was like ok
I'll start it
people started turning up when we
started meetup groups I've had monthly
meetups for about three years long story
short I've written an article for the
publication the talks are recorded since
the last two years and some of the talks
have made it to the YouTube channel
which is awesome including which is the
best part I did a talk with my other
co-organizer Tanya Deutsch who couldn't
be here tonight but he's saying hi to
everyone we did a talk on going from
learning to code to get your first job
as a self-taught developer and it's also
on the YouTube channel so yeah that's
the most amazing part like I started
free code camp and studying it because I
wanted to get my first developer job and
I did which is awesome so
thank you hi everyone i'm richard from
also from leads or johny johny Bissell's
from the icon that is Johnny vigil and I
now live in Oslo actually I've come from
your neck of the woods so I want a local
leader still in Leeds and when local
leaders in Oslo I have some wonder free
code camp Instagram Sochi on Instagram
that's me who's posting and wrote some
articles for the medium post and there's
a YouTube video on the free code camp
youtube of mine as well
and yes that's a lot awesome well thank
you everybody for coming out here you
all have given up your time you're gonna
up your energy you know free coke camps
a small nonprofit we don't have the
resources to fly everybody out and put
them up in a nice hotel so you all have
figured out ways to come out here and
stay and that means an incredible amount
to me and to the rest of the free
cooking community as well so it's
wonderful to be here together in Dublin
and to be able to mingle and to learn
more about one another so I think at
this point what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get some more English tea all
right I'm sorry
Irish tea I dodged the blow there right
those those potentially hazardous so I'm
gonna get somewhere iris-t and then we
can sit down here on this beautiful
couch overlooking this beautiful evening
and I'm gonna try to talk to as many of
you all as possible and just interview
you and learn more about you so anybody
who wants to be interviewed just kind of
when you see that a not interview is
anything come over and jump on the couch
I'll talk to you be assertive don't be
shy this is this is gonna be so much fun
and I see tons of people each at all of
it's super supportive thanks everybody
for tuning in and yeah we'll make a
highlight video like we did with the New
York
the event and then we'll share that with
the community - which should be able to
so all of you are able to help give
people some context into what they can
expect striking out on their own trying
to learn software development and trying
to get their first developer job and I
think pretty much pretty much everybody
here has their career has directly
benefited from taking that jump from
saying I can learn software development
I can do it I can go out I can get a job
I can I can freelance I can have a
career as a software developer and it's
just that that faith in yourself and
that willingness to reach out to other
people in the community and ask for help
and then turn around and help other
people in the community to do the same
and that's precisely the spirit we want
to capture and convey to the rest of the
free cocaine community which at this
point is millions of people around the
world many of whom have never coded
before and are eager to get started so
we can provide a lot of guidance for
them so I'll be right over here in just
a minute I'm just gonna grab some tea I
want to have a special thank you for
this gentleman whom I'm gonna rotate the
camera here he's like in shock that I'm
thinking him directly
there he is look he's got a stylish
blazer yeah so I'm worried that my fall
over so this is Matthew Potter come over
here Matthew braved the airlines and the
airport's coming over and he arrived
this morning with me on separate flights
in Dublin and Matthews gonna be doing
our AV he is a seasoned AV guy streamer
and he streams regularly on Twitch he
has a he has a Saturday morning cartoon
check it out if you ever wake up super
early just Google you know Saturday
morning cartoons which you'll probably
pull up is his stream you gonna eat some
breakfast cereal and watch 90s cartoons
like x-men and
Jemm and he-man and stuff like that
right Thundercats yeah Thundercats on
there there's a lot of stuff so thanks
so much I'm gonna give you the mic while
I get the tea awesome
yes so essentially what I do a frico
camp is I help out doing having a
computer that's sitting in a closet
that's running headless and stri or
drives the music channel so I can
officially say I have the most content
on YouTube for free code camp even
though nobody's seen my face except for
New York in here damn it I'm sorry for
your loss
I'm also Canadian so that's why the
story is there but yeah so we're gonna
be setting up here momentarily for the
interviews the camera I'm gonna cut it
out for a quick seconds I want to make a
minor modification anybody on the stream
is probably seeing a bit of a stutter
I'm gonna fix that I swear I'll do my
best and we're gonna make sure that
Quincy's all teed up because of his
flights and if you knew how long it was
for him to get here
you'd be like oh here's Morty send him
tea but yeah we'll be we'll be right
back and as they did used to say on
Saturday mornings after these messages
we'll be right back
hey I'm here with Brianna Swift let me
pop her information up on the screen for
you so Brianna welcome you flew in today
from Berlin yes thank you we only have
one like so Brianna you have been
involved with free coke camp this is
basically the beginning maybe you can
just give us a high-level overview of
your involvement with free coke camp and
and your transition into being a
developer yeah so I found free code camp
why was an elementary school music
teacher I was trying to learn how to
code I love kids I love teaching music
but I knew it wasn't a career that I
wanted to do forever so I was like what
can I learn how to do without having to
quit my job and go back to school
because I couldn't afford to do that and
I thought the people that make the
internet are probably the first ones to
put all of that information for free on
the internet and so I did codecademy
mostly JavaScript type stuff and found
my way onto free code camp I was really
involved on Twitter that was my only
community cuz I was really kind of alone
while I was learning and went through
the free code camp challenges and as
soon as I started doing that it started
to get involved more in the chat room
which there was no forum at that point
and started doing some pair programming
and streaming that so free code camp
really not only taught me the
fundamentals that I needed for you know
for development and for software but
also gave me a community in a place to
you know commiserate almost how hard it
is to learn how to go yeah and so you
said you were a teacher can you talk a
little bit more about like where you
were teaching what you were teaching
yeah so I taught elementary school music
which was kindergarten through fifth
grade so like you think recorders or
like xylophones that kind of thing and
it was in central Illinois so pretty
rural Illinois
which I love there are so many things
about it I love it
but the thing as I reflect back on it
teaching from my perspective in an
elementary school music setting was
generally going to be the same thing
with of course you know some changes
over the years but what really drew me
to tech is that I can work from home
sometimes I can't work from home when
you're teaching kindergarten you've
gotta have to be in the room and and
it's always changing you know I always
am gonna be challenged to learn
something new in a hurry and I think
that's really exciting yeah and so you
said early on you were communicating
with other developers on Twitter and
kind of working to build your own
community and your own support network
there that you could commiserate with
and how did you discover free code camp
because I think it launched right when
you found it you know one of the first
few be able to find it if I remember
right I feel like you tweeted at me I
think I was tweeting I was like hashtag
like women who code hashtag women in
tech I was just putting anything out
there and I could be misremembering but
I feel like you tweeted it and you're
like hey you should try free code camp
and I was like okay and I did and then I
stuck with it I got lucky
awesome yeah I saw your energy and I
remember exactly the the tweet I sent
but you know at the time I was reaching
out to people who I thought would be
good citizens within the community and
who seemed really passionate and
energetic so yeah so you joined the free
code camp community and I remember early
on we were doing like these live coding
sessions every Tuesday and you quickly
took kind of charge on those and you
would regularly stream yourself coding
can you share a little bit about that
yeah yeah so I think my first one was
with Terra kilobyte with Nathan shout
out Terry kilobyte um and I was super
intimidated at first I was like
everybody's gonna see how dumb I am
everybody's gonna see that I don't know
what I'm doing I'm gonna you know talk
weird which I'm sure I did but it was
really addictive not only because it was
really motivating so I was you
once you're showing up and people are
watching you you have to kind of finish
what you're doing but also it's so
energizing to see that other people can
relate and I found out I tell people now
if you're ever working on something and
you can't you're stuck I think the best
thing you can do is live stream because
and there's people here like Ben and
Jonathan specifically and Nathan Terry
kilobyte I would be streaming I don't
know why people would be watching me
because I was a mess I didn't know what
I was doing and they will get so
frustrated watching me stream and I did
that I wasn't doing it right that they
would be like just let me can I can I
call with you like can I help you do
this and I learned so much in those
times like the community of developers
is so generous with their knowledge
everybody wants to help you so instead
of feeling intimidated about streaming
like oh they're gonna think I'm dumb
instead it was like they want to help me
learn and get better and they really did
it was it was really inspiring and
helpful and you took a lot of this
inspiration and a lot of your early
insights as a new developer and you were
able to turn around and teach a lot of
other people and the main medium we use
for that was video you talked about some
of your early videos that we put on
freako camps YouTube channel yeah yeah
those those are fun I think it's a
really fun challenge to take something
that is thought of as complex and make
it sound really simple
one of my favorite professors dr.
Robinson at UMKC when I was studying
music said that you should say anything
in seven words or less you can't say it
in seven words or less you're not saying
it well enough and I know my videos are
more than seven seven words but applying
that concept of things like what is the
Internet you know like how do I mean how
do all these things work I think is an
exciting challenge for me just
intellectually but it also makes these
really important tech khamseh concepts
so much more approachable and it's like
hey you actually can do this these
aren't so complex you don't have to go
take you know take a four year degree to
understand this it's a pro you can do
this it's okay yeah and based on your
videos on YouTube and the skills that
you were able to build up just learning
the code on your own and through
different communities
you were able to eventually get a job
can you talk a little bit about your job
and how you got it yeah yes I work at
github which is not where I thought I
could be working when I started learning
to code I'm a trainer so most of the
time I'm talking to developers about how
to use git and github so regardless of
what language they're programming in
regardless of what type of projects how
big their team is everybody should
probably be using version control and
git is not the simplest thing to wrap
your head around so it's a similar
challenge to these computer science
concepts like how can we make this
simple and approachable this you know
that transition was weird because it's
going from elementary school music
teacher to working at github is kind of
a jump but but I think working with
those videos specifically and saying how
can we take these difficult concepts and
make them approachable to anybody is
something that really primed me for
working at github so I think even if
somebody is going through free code camp
and if you're going through free code
camp and you're like I don't know if I
necessarily see myself as a full-time
developer that's okay like there are so
many places for you that are perfect for
you that you might just not know exists
like I didn't know that this job existed
but I love it
right and as a trainer it's a
combination of doing development and
also figuring out ways to teach
different mechanics of get and github
and any coding best practices things
like that can you what would a typical
day for you be like it could go a couple
different ways usually it's so we break
it into one or one of two either I'm on
site you know with a customer so
somebody that their company uses github
their company says our developers need
to know how to use getting github so I
show up let's talk about getting get
home for the next couple days and we go
through some projects and get everybody
as up to speed as possible but on the
other days it's resting from travel or
what I really love is working on
projects of scaling that kind of
knowledge so a really exciting project
that we're working on now is called
github learning lab that's it's lab
github.com and it's free tutorials on
how to use github
but it's a Probot app so it's a github
app that will walk you through the
process on github so you don't have to
go through like all the different rabbit
holes which I know I experienced when I
was learning to code you go on one
tutorial links you to another tutorial
and that link see this other thing
before you know it you're reading about
something completely different
right we try to keep it native to github
so you can stay focused on what you're
actually trying to learn so we're
working a lot on developing new courses
for that and I think it's really
exciting awesome and one big change
going from an elementary school teacher
and Illinois is now you work for github
and github is primarily a remote focused
organization can you describe what that
means
yeah yeah so most of our the majority of
github employees work remotely so we
don't have to show up to any specific
office the professional services team
that I'm on is a hundred percent remote
actually work from Berlin now from my
home which is amazing working from home
is awesome but also a challenge you have
to be really organized and keep your own
schedule you have to know what you want
to accomplish in a given day you know
make sure that things are prioritized
but it also gives you so much freedom
I can work pretty much distraction free
and the hours that work for me of course
I still have to work with my team it's
I'm the only one there's two of us now
on the training team in Europe and the
rest of them are in the United States so
there's a lot of things to work around
but I think free code camp in many ways
prepared me for that because we were
working really a synchronously we
weren't in the same office I think
things are moving that way in general
and technology yeah and I'm a huge
proponent of remote working and
asynchronous especially I think the
ability to to sleep in and if you if you
don't feel like giving up and and then
just working later or you know really
drilling in and using your best judgment
about when to to say this is a priority
I need to finish this even if it means
working through the weekend just having
that agency and being able to make those
decisions for yourself I think that's a
really powerful thing for a 21st century
knowledge worker and it really empowers
them to manage themselves much more than
in a traditional office setting where
you have a manager and they have a
manager and I mean github his embrace
managers I know initially they didn't
even really have that much in the way of
managers but what are some things that
so I guess what are some things that
excite you most about github in the
direction that the organization is going
that's an exciting question so I think
there's so many things that I'm excited
about anyone I talked to whether they
work at github or they work with github
is developing something awesome there
are so many amazing projects being built
on github so many amazing minds using
github as a tool you know as a product
as a platform really about where they
can share ideas and collaborate I think
even someone that you know works at
github what I envision for the tool is
probably only a small percentage of what
it's actually capable of once it's in
the hands of the brilliant developers
that are gonna be using it so I don't
even know if I can imagine you know even
in my wildest dreams I don't think I
could really see what's gonna happen
things like you know Detroit Water
Project you know things that people are
building with open-source taking it
beyond our traditional understanding of
open source software open source
education open source you know social
you know social growth and how can we
work better as a global community it's
it's so exciting I hope I hope to see
that leverage soon what are your
near-term goals for both your time at
your career at github and of course just
general projects that are of interest to
you so Learning Lab that I mentioned
earlier is a big one I think there's a
there's a lot of potential there to just
help help people learn how people teach
how people understand the same as free
code camp right open sourcing education
making things more accessible to people
that I think if somebody wants to learn
something they should be able to learn
and it's hard it's it's not that easy
and it should be so I think whether it's
at github or something greater than that
that's all that's where my goals are at
awesome well Briana thank you so much
for flying in from Berlin and you
recently got married so I hope your
husband is thanked thanks to him for
letting us borrow you for a weekend and
I am excited to see what you do and
certainly we would welcome additional
videos on get and github and and other
concepts as time permits for your
creative because I just sent out a video
anthology of it's about 25 minutes and
it's a we put together I think maybe 20
different videos that you've created
over the past few years about how
computers work how the internet works so
everybody be sure to check that out I
think that's pretty prominent on the
YouTube channel and be sure to follow
Breanna on Twitter because she she
shares a lot of exciting stuff she's
gonna pop up for Twitter information
again real quick
it's just Brianna Marie won 3-2 so thank
you so much Brianna for joining us thank
you Quincy thanks everybody
awesome thanks again hey come on over
man yeah good to meet you in person I'm
gonna pull up your name and information
I've got this great app that Matthew
Potter put together yeah we just had to
scroll through here easier enough but
I've ordered my first name yeah so while
I'm doing this
why don't you just tell us a little bit
about yourself Pete sure sir my name is
Pete and I'm a data scientist based in
London and I write for and help out at
the medium publication I've been doing
that since about October last year so
almost a year now and it's really fun
it's really interesting to see what
articles we receive and and you know so
curating them and helping it in them to
you know heist and we we like to put up
yeah and you you have written some
incredibly exhaustive articles on
different aspects of data science and
math
and machine learning what got you into
the field such a good question so I
originally started out as a biologist
and I learned a lot of statistics and
all of a you know machine learning
concepts but was really interesting too
when I began looking into learning to
program it was really interesting to see
how there's a lot of overlap between
some of the skills I learned and some of
the skills I wanted to you know start to
start working with so yeah it's a field
of sort of it's it's it's very
fast-moving it's it's always something
new to learn
it's just making fire really interesting
I've always enjoyed statistics yeah so
how do you keep on top of all the rapid
changes in the fields of machine I mean
it's probably one of the most dynamic
and rapid growing corpus of knowledge
how do you stay on top of that so I
think it's constant reading really I I
always look for new articles which come
out a few of my friends work in research
as well so I talk to them and hear you
know the latest ideas but mostly it's
it's about reading the documentation as
well there's a balance between
understand the theory of machine
learning and also seeing how it works in
practice and I find for example the
scikit-learn documentation is really
good one it tells you how to use the you
know the techniques but also explains
the background of it as well which I
find really interesting so scikit-learn
I believe is a Python library do you do
a lot of your data science work in
Python
so mostly Python yes I also use our and
sequel for sort of database of data
engineering tile tile work so yeah I
really really like Python that's
probably my my you know favorite
language I also know a little bit of
JavaScript I started learning that on
the three co-come curriculum I seem
decided that web development I found I
found CSS teacher okay that was my
problem so yeah I chose to specialize in
data science instead
well I would encourage you to look at
into data visualization I think you
probably I haven't read every single one
of your articles recently but I for a
long time I was the one who was actually
proofreading and editing them before we
published it now we've built out this
amazing editorial team which led by Abby
and you're one of the major editors
there and it's just so amazing having
somebody with so much domain expertise
who can really go in and take a good
look at these articles and kind of fact
check them and make sure that they they
look good and representative of the
state for the field
what is your editorial workflow like
about how frequently will you check in
and find articles that you're interested
in editing and publishing I see so we do
receive a lot of articles was always
something to work on I check in daily I
actually take my lunch breaks at work as
an opportunity to you know see what
there is and review some of the articles
and if I see one I think I can I can
help you know Adam get to you know the
standard we want then you know I'll
claim an article in an evening I'll work
on it and send it to Abby for you know
final review and publishing so it's yeah
it's good I think the main bulk for work
is is its fact-checking just being sure
about what what the author's written is
is 100% a okay to put out and a lot of
formatting as well it's one of the
things I learn from from from yourself
actually from when I used to publish my
articles for free free when you were
running the publication the writing
style keeping things really you know
concise and easy to read there's a lot
of our readers are internationally don't
necessarily speak English as a first
language so it's very important to make
sure what we put out is accessible yeah
and what are your favorite types of
articles your favorite topics to edit
it's a good question I really like some
more general articles like really sort
of like overviews of like why topics I
think I think it's a balance as well I
mean I really like in-depth tutorial
articles as well where you can really
see you know at the start what you're
going to build and follow them along and
see
you know how something works in practice
so yeah I mean I guess it's hard to pick
an exact type of article I really like I
think yeah we receive a lot of very
varied and very interesting articles
aside from contributing to freako camp
and editing and writing so many great
in-depth articles on statistics and data
science machine learning what are your
goals for the rest of 2018 and 2019 so
the company I'm working up we're a
startup and we've recently announced and
launched some really exciting products
we actually teach kids how to code
and we produce computer kits and we've
got some really exciting products coming
out so yeah we're looking to sort of
ship those and that's that's why I'm
working on 2018 awesome and tell me just
a little bit more about that like do you
have like hardware products or yeah so
we produce the hardware so we have
computer kits and a one kit and we also
have a software ecosystem as well so
people can go in and they can learn to
code and they can share their creations
on this online community we have and
it's it's really interesting there's a
lot of synergy between you know what I
work on for my day job and you know what
free code come is setting out to achieve
as well so yeah I really really enjoy
spending all my time doing that
basically awesome if people were
interested and I'm not sure how whether
the product is totally ready for people
that going and buy for their schools or
for their kids but if they wanted to
learn more about the the company and and
you what you all are up to what's the
name of the company and where can I find
it sure we're Conor we're at caño dot me
and we're also in retail in the US so
yeah ka and ome ok great KN o dot any
that Emmy okay
okay know me okay great and thank you
again so much for everything you've done
for the community it's always a pleasure
you know you're
you always take such a detailed nuanced
look at articles and it really shows and
your articles have been so in-depth and
I often pull them up and and when people
submit articles and I'm like well take a
look at this this is a good example of
what works on medium and what works with
the developer crowd so thank you again
for kind of setting like really
trailblazing and and setting a really
good example for other technical writers
and developers thank you thanks Peter
so I'm gonna pop Peters uh information
backup okay thank you and we're joined
here Richie how's your last name
pronounced C toilet seat totally yeah
yeah we're cheesy totally have a seat
Richie
[Music]
welcome so you're joining us from
Johannesburg awesome well thank you so
much for flying out man I mean that I
think you may have traveled I don't know
you you may have traveled even farther
than I did about 14 hours over and and
at is so y'all but just over ten hours
but it felt like 12 days yeah but it was
all good it's so far it's been amazing
I'm you know I love the atmosphere I
love the four seasons in one morning
which is what we experienced yesterday
when I arrived y'all so like I landed
around 6:30 in the morning and on my way
here on my way to where the guest house
is you know it was nice and cloudy was a
little bit cloudy it was comfortable and
the clouds open up it was nice and sunny
and then shortly after that it just
started raining out of nowhere it was
like massive winds and and and stuff
yeah so it's yeah it's it seems to be
like you know people are used to this
stuff so yeah I'm just taking it in as
as I go along how was your flight
it was arduous so I woke up at 6:00 a.m.
Friday morning us time then I flew to
Newark which is like New Jersey and then
I waited there all day and then I was
able to fly to Reykjavik in Iceland hey
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly and
then flew here and I just arrived a few
hours ago so I slept on the plane I took
a little power nap and it was really fun
because Matthew Potter was joking I was
like I was like yeah wake me up before
you yell and he said oh you want me to
wake you up with wake me up before I go
go you know the lamb song and he has
this super powered laptop I don't know
what it is it's incredibly loud soft
sleeping and all of a sudden I hear
cheetah bug Jada bug I swear like there
was like a party outside the room so I
yeah so I just took a shower and I was
good to go
but now I'm drinking my Irish tea and
that's helping wake me up yeah but yeah
man thanks so much for flying out so
tell us a little bit about what you do
you do many things within the freako
camp community just give us an overview
of some of the things you do yeah so I
mean we met a couple of years back you
know free cocaine was still in its early
days and stuff so so what I do currently
is basically run meetups I'm a core
admin for free cocaine Johnny's burg
there's a couple of other guys that some
came and went and someone stole they put
some a domain so my active wouldn't need
it who needs be but I'm generally like
you know organized stuff and hosts the
meetups themselves and it's quite funny
and it's very interesting like I mean
we've got a community of about 1,500
people and we get at least one someone
asked me to join like on a daily basis
it's just insane which is amazing so
which means that you know the word is
getting out there and people are
recognizing what we're doing and they
actually see the value in what we're
doing which is fantastic
yeah so like I mean the funny thing is
this so you you put up like create an
event on Facebook I know a Facebook
group so it's free code camp John is
back on Facebook go check it out so you
know we're having our next meetup at the
end of this month 29th of
anyway so like you'll have a couple of
people just like RSVP and they go get
all hyped up and excited like yeah I'm
gonna do this and then anything you get
like five or eight people you turn up
but it's for me personally like it's
it's those sessions that I really
appreciate and really enjoy because you
sort of like sieve through you know like
I don't know how to put it back it's the
people that end up coming eventually
coming it's people that are truly
passionate and really really believe in
you know what pre-code CEM is you know
offering is and it's sort of like
reminds me of of myself like pretty much
like two three years ago when I started
I was that guy pretty much like I would
rock up or I could be like me and a
couple of other people but like for me
it was just you know like just getting
in a lot of information getting as much
information as possible about you know
software development and as far as I
mean you would obviously know that you
know that the learning never stops right
so so look I really appreciate people
that that make it to the to the meetups
and granted I understand some people
cannot you know make it you know they'll
have other plans so something comes up
into that sort of thing and so I get all
of that but you know I just shout out
and say thank you to the people that
constantly come to to our meetups and
funny enough their Ontario justice I sir
about that so I was we had a party at at
my company lost a couple of weeks ago
and I mentioned to one of the top guys
and I said I'm going to Dublin in a
couple of weeks time okay cool cool so
what are you gonna do they and then I
obviously still the whole story about
freako Cameron why not and they were
like mind blown I told you guys make me
series so they were all ecstatic and
excited about it and I remember one of
the top guys there
Jimmy's like now do you like seriously
when you come back like we don't don't
you worry about the next venue you can
totally use our office we'll even
organize coffee for you guys so I'm
definitely gonna take him out Jimmy I'm
gonna take you up on that offer okay
so yeah now with the communities growing
and we see a lot of people coming in I
mean just trip coming here I'm a married
couple of guys in our chamber which is a
International Airport in Joburg the one
guy actually his he was coming to meet
his future colleagues he got a job offer
here in Dublin as a back-end developer
but so we obviously told him the reason
why I was travelling to Dublin as well
and he was also like it's so funny like
when I explained this story because I'm
so passionate about it
but when it finally hits the chord and
you see people's eyes they just like
dilate for a second they're like wow how
come I've never heard about this thing
so obviously exchanged numbers and
whatnot and he's like no no I need to
get my cousin into this thing and this
what I just told you now like it happens
so often I and I love telling this story
because I truly believe in it I've been
in it I mean it's been like almost three
years now right yeah looking around you
and seeing these guys I mean just drink
some incredible work and I'm very
passionate about it done I just want to
see the next free kokum 2.0 two point
three point oh whatever we can take this
thing right yeah we're building we're
building an events platform that'll make
it easier for people in Johannesburg
when they're just using free code camp
to room it'll remind them hey there's an
event in you know at the nearby office
where you're having your next event
so I I'm optimistic that that will help
even more people who are already in
Johannesburg who don't realize that
you're having all these in-person events
that will help get them involved as well
another aspect of it I mean it's we were
talking about how else myself in
evidence we were talking about how else
we can contribute like is this all we
can do i you know is that like how do we
take it to the next level and I'm right
my response to that was like that's a
very good question brother what do you
think
and he's over there so he gave me his
peace of mind like for me I think for
now is like we need to continue doing
what we've been doing because personally
I mean for me right the the reason why I
believe in this and I why I'm still
doing what I what I'm doing now is that
I see value in this you know I truly
believe like this is one way that we can
and I know it sounds very like up in the
sky but I really believe like this is
one way of actually tackling poverty and
I see people that are frustrated in
their jobs people that they just you
know they just go to work just for the
heck of it but they don't enjoy it you
know and for me I strongly believe in
they're like you have to really enjoy
what you do and I absolutely love what
I'm doing right now and thanks to free
code camp and I think the way just back
to my original point was that how to
take it forward is first of all we need
to keep doing what we're doing
you know don't drop the standard and
obviously think of other ways of how we
can improve it
whether is I don't know like maybe
writing articles if you would say you
were doing like you should stuff or you
hosting made ups maybe just you know
think of other ways of contributing more
or at least getting other people to pull
the same passion that you have so that
they can also continue in and contribute
to the platform in in different ways
yeah and if for those of you who are
watching who are interested in some ways
you can contribute
aside from leading study groups which I
think it's probably the most important
and immediate thing because that way
you're able to actively get people in
your community reach out to your
neighbors and your friends and get them
into coding this is a skill that I I
encourage everybody to pick up even if
you don't envision yourself working as a
software engineer at some point in the
future these skills are going to be
incredibly helpful regardless where your
career is so so by running local study
groups like you're doing in Johannesburg
you can really bring a lot of people in
just get them some basic exposure and so
they even realized that this is a skill
they can learn and build up their
confidence so
I would say some some ways that your
community can absolutely help would be
adding captions and subtitles I know
most people in South Africa speak
English but you also have Afrikaans and
their other other local languages that
some people in your your study group may
know that would that would help
and of course creating more articles and
creating creating videos those would all
be tremendously helpful absolutely and
funny mention that that's not so long
ago in fact I think in preparation of
the next meetup a lady commented on
Facebook group and the question was are
you meetups suitable for kids and like
that cook me off of God because I like I
you know it's not something that's you
know someone asked just like that and it
was like and I didn't respond
immediately I just thought about it for
a second I think I probably slept on it
I don't remember exactly but my response
to me was very similar I said look if a
person who wants to you know come to our
meetups as long as they can read and
write you know I think they're good to
go and I strongly believe in that I mean
you can correct me from if I'm wrong but
like I think there's no age limit when
when it comes to learning and
specifically software development as
long as you know you can look at code
and you can read and you can write I
strongly believe that you can actually
manage to learn and and you know and
encode so my advice was basically like
look you know maybe just because she
hasn't been to the meetup I said look
just come to an X Mira check it out and
if you think is suitable for your son or
daughter you know then you can invite
them there for the next meter so
hopefully we'll see her at the end of
this month and hopefully we'll see some
kids coming up in the in the in you know
in the next meetups but yeah it's it's
just been incredible I mean the last the
last year we we've I think we've done
more made ups than we have there was a
period where we didn't have as many met
ups but then I always take you from from
the community from the
the members of the group so whenever
someone says hey you interested should
we do it and then we just put it
together and you know and that's how we
roll y'all and I just I'm looking
forward to obviously like continuing
having like a more regular credence
cadence and yeah I cuz and also another
request that came in in one of our last
meet ups was one of the members said
they would like to have more technical
meet up so I think with with the offer
that I got for my community to have the
next meetup in in the offices that will
give us the space and the environment
for you know for something like that to
happen so I'm looking forward to that
yeah awesome well congratulations on
getting your company on board is like a
venue sponsor and yeah I totally agree I
think if kids are mature enough to come
freako camp as a community is really
aimed at adults primarily their other
great initiatives like code.org Khan
Academy and especially coderdojo I I
love what coder dojos doing and hack
Club is another good one that's focused
at the high school level but but we aim
to make these events totally acceptable
for kids and we want to keep them you
know professional and friendly and
welcoming so yeah absolutely
if somebody has a kid and that they are
confident their cake will have a good
time and get a lot out of it
I would encourage them to bring it
Ritchie it's been such a pleasure man
thank you so much for flying out here
congratulations on all your recent
achievements your job and how you're
leading the community it's amazing and I
think you're really setting an example
for so many people around the world who
want to create local study groups and
and help people in their communities
learn to code it's it's only a pleasure
a Quincy like I've I mean we I'm just
was thinking the other day like we we
made like just a couple of years ago and
it's you know our relationship has grown
and the community has grown and I've
loved everything that
you soften and the team have been doing
and yeah I'm looking forward to the
future and to freako camp thanks again
yeah likewise Cheers hey hey pleasure
absolutely
well David you are a prolific writer
among other things and I think you have
a very interesting background can you
tell the audience a little bit about
yourself and how you got into coding and
writing my code okay first of all Quincy
I'm really grateful to you that you
created free code came because I think
it was really the major helper for me to
switch my careers because as you
mentioned I was working as a lawyer I
have a law degree and then I was working
as a lawyer for two years but then I got
eventually a little bit frustrated and I
was wondering what to do next so I was
checking online courses and stuff and if
anything first I checked some Harvard
course about cooking about molecular
gastronomy and I spent like three months
doing that but I said to me okay I
cannot be cool because I'm sweating and
in the kitchen there's a lot of hot in
here so I couldn't cook so I try to
watching for something else and then I
find first some of course on udemy about
programming and CSS HTML in JavaScript
and I try that but then it was just a
tutorial you know building things that
are people built so it was kind of it
was great I can motivate it but it was
just a first level and then I discovered
free code camp and those algorithms and
it was basically a different dimension
for me because before I was just
creating stuff according to tutorials
but with the with algorithms I need to
really understand and at first I got
really frustrated because I think oh my
god is so difficult I can it be
developer but then it really just would
be better and better and finally I got
really confident and really I started
learning to code during the weekends and
on the evenings and it eventually it
took me seven months to switch from a
lawyer to develop purchase coding into
on the week
good night so I'm really great for free
code came because it really motivated me
to see all the people doing the same
thing miss although so why I decide for
contributing for free code came by
writing articles because you know a free
code camp community helped me to became
developer and I also wanted to
contribute to it by by showing people
concepts that were difficult for me so I
try to like describe them in a way that
are more understandable for me and in a
way that I want them to be to see them
when I learn them because there were no
resources before
yeah and that's I think the part of my
story and maybe just the the main thing
what I decided to change switch the
careers was that as a lawyer I didn't
see the results of my work and as a as a
programmer I mean you might consume that
log and you see the result is it's so
motivating you just write code and you
see the result I love this and this is
why I love programming
yeah with programming there's a very
tight feedback loop you can at any point
you can see what the effect is you can
push an application live and look at
your analytics and see people are using
it how people are using it it's it's
unlike any other field really I mean you
could argue that in teaching you can see
you know students faces and and whether
they're comprehending things and see
them turn around and apply it but there
are very few fields where you can
immediately get so much feedback on your
work I just want to underscore the
magnitude of your accomplishment David
because you said in seven months just
studying nights and weekends while
working as a lawyer full time you were
able to transition into tech and tell us
a little bit about what you're doing now
okay now I work as a JavaScript
developer for for the digital agency in
Prague called blueberry and doing
typical phone and stuff I'm working with
react most of the time and now I will
basically maybe start with a view as
well so I'm really looking forward to it
because I never do it and I also pretty
excited about reason ml yeah and I'm
pretty excited that in my company were
internal projects or you can try
different technologies and we were also
able to do it and come
and build our recent application called
called planning poker about scrum where
you do planning poker build application
for it so it's really interesting and
and another thing I love about
programming is that is that the way how
it progresses I mean when I started
programming there was jQuery and angular
okay that's some react I know what it is
and basically it so fast and now I like
how it's moving forward there I mean my
to-do list it's so long and I never be
able to like to try all the technologies
but I laugh all the people who have what
they do and you can learn from them so I
maybe I just and us could I do
yeah also right as I mentioned blog
posts for medium publications when it
will help me it helped me it helps me
and the audience is because for me when
I caught something you know when you
caught something you basically don't
care about anything you just said okay
it works so that's good but when you
write a blog post about it you need to
like really understand you will need to
go deeper and eventually after that I
even start going to conferences and
speak about programming and it really
helps me even more because at a
conference we have quick QA right qna
people might ask you and dislike most
restful thing for the first time because
you need to go really deep because
people might ask you different questions
so I know what I really love about all
these stuff free cooked Emma conferences
at you that I learned something like I
share with us and the thing that I just
learned it it makes I think more
approachable for other people because
I'm on this level they were there on the
level I were before so I'm not that like
not at all the high level so I like can
understand what they need to how they
need to learn so that's why I'm doing it
yeah that's great so essentially what
you're doing by writing these articles
and giving talks at conferences is
you're almost overtraining to make sure
you really have mastered something so
well that you can explain it and it's
interesting because we were just talking
with Breanna many thing go and she said
you don't really understand something
until you can explain it in like seven
words
because so much often when I write
article there are I just got stuck and I
was thinking why is it working I mean
why why and really forces you because
you need to understand to to some person
who doesn't know so so many stuff like
you do because you are into the topic
you truly and in a understandable way
that's oh I think it's like challenging
for you to learning new technology
because sometimes there aren't any of
resources and these resources are often
wide by people who are really good at it
but sometimes for you as a beginner it's
more challenging though so that's why
I'm trying to write it for like most
approachable as I Candice why I'm kind
of perfection is so like when I write
article okay I write it it's not
complicated but I spend so much time
just to reading it reading it sending to
my colleagues for proofreading it's like
really write erotic article is not the
most difficult part the difficult part
is just to make it approachable for
people coming from different levels of
their knowledge well thank you so much
David for all your amazing articles that
you've contributed and I've enjoyed
reading so much so many of them and of
course I'm very inspired by your just
rapid transition from working as a
lawyer to working as a as a developer
and working with all these cutting-edge
tools you know reason ml very exciting
stuff where you said you're getting
ready to learn some view so we hope that
you'll continue to write these amazing
articles
yeah I'm looking forward I I was also
playing with idea to make some
screencast and I was discussing with
with other people here and I think it'll
be really useful and again again
Quincy thank you very much for a free
code came because it makes really
difference for people like on the whole
planet I think well thank you so much
that means so much to me and I hope you
have a wonderful time in Dublin are you
gonna are you gonna come run with us
tomorrow so I I have my running shoes
running running t-shirt and my behalf of
my luggage is just to running stuff so I
guess I should because I just brought so
much stuff with me great hopefully it'll
be nice and cool here the weather is
very dynamic in Dublin
tomorrow it should be nicer I just
checked the weather and should be like
not so much cloud to so many clouds so
alright well I'm great I'm looking
forward to running around Phoenix Park
with you tomorrow Cheers
likewise thanks again David yeah Oh
perfect
hey James Phillips thank you do my best
and next we have a man whom I have
worked very closely with for years yeah
Evaristo yeah thank you so much for
making it out of here and perhaps you
can just give us I'll give you a very
quick introduction so Evaristo has
basically been leaving free co-champs
data science effort he is one of the
most prominent people in the data
science chat room on Gitter and he's
done a number of different analyses both
on medium and a kegel of different data
sets we've we've made public of course
when we make data sets public we're very
responsible about the disclosure and can
you know cognizant of privacy concerns
and things like that so we have these
huge public data sets and Evaristo has
analyzed them extensively thank you for
joining us every stow yeah I mean where
the videos from Portugal I'm sorry I got
mixed up yeah so tell us a little bit
about I feel yeah so so tell us a little
about about what you're working on out
in Portugal
Eduardo and and you're leading the study
group there well I first knew free code
camp in the beginning of 2017 and I was
a civil engineering
and I was not happy with my career I
wanted to reboot into into programming
and when I met free code camp I'm at the
right path to start learning how to
program I've tried a lot of boot camps
without effort but with free code camp
it was very very easy to follow follow
up and at the same time that I was
studying I started to motivate people to
study with me I started as same time as
wrong Eric and together we started the
study group in our city and we
impersonated also the starting of the
study group in Lisbon the capital of
Portugal and we are doing that effort
every week even after we get about our
jobs yeah I've rebooted my career in
five months studying more or less 10
hours per day but it was net it was 5
months and I got from civil engineering
to a front-end developer yeah and so
Eduardo you said within 5 months you
were able to transition from civil
engineer to developer just studying on
your own yeah yeah correct because when
I found free code camp I found the right
path I was in a big dot of what I should
study first and what I should study
after that and with free code camp I got
the correct path and I followed that
path and it worked very well I also got
a mentor Thank You Miguel coca for
supporting me mentor ease it was very
helpful in my study and I got a job very
quick with you even though you've gone a
full time job and you've made the
successful transition you're still
giving back to the community and you're
still helping run the local study group
talk talk a little bit about the the
group and how your leadership of it
of course we have we have two main
events we have one event that we call
the socially event where where we try to
join the local community of senior
programmers with the students and we
have a second event called the study
group where we focus just on solving
challenges and it's working great it's
amazing how people are motivating and
are studying and are growing with us
step by step and when they are ready to
enter in the in the market we have jobs
for them really yeah it's it's great
it's amazing yeah so when you say people
are able to enter the job market how
many people within your study group have
gotten developer jobs do you think yeah
first me see let me tell you that we are
in the south of Portugal so it's a small
town like 50,000 inhabitants and in the
last year we got five five developers
ready to start working and they started
working so I think it's a nice
percentage so basically one out of
10,000 people in your town has gotten a
developer job thanks largely to your
efforts and your community outreach also
after that I started started writing on
medium because I felt the need to
contribute more to free code camp
so I started to write about react that's
the the main area in which I'm working
nowadays thank you for writing these
articles so in Portugal of course you
speak Portuguese and and it's also a
huge language in Brazil and Brazil is I
think the third largest country for
freako camp in terms of total number of
people who who use it and frequently I
talked to developers from Portugal from
Brazil and other Portuguese speaking
countries and they have there's
definitely a strong desire to have to be
able to read about technical concepts in
their native Portuguese and since you
already started writing articles I'm
just gonna put this out there
would you be interested at some point in
potentially writing articles about
technology in Portuguese yeah yeah of
course totally agree with that I want to
start writing in Portuguese for the big
communities that we have because
Portuguese is the fifth most spoken
language in the world but at the same
time I feel the needs to motivate people
to learn English because when you start
working in a remote team or something
like that you need to interact with
people from all over the world so in
spite of having a way to learn in
Portuguese you also need to train your
English skills I think that that's very
that's important to train other people
in your study group that are getting
jobs how many of them are getting jobs
at local companies versus I don't know
how many multinational corporations and
have like branches there but well what
would you say the ratio of like local
employers and small businesses versus
multinational employers okay basically
Portugal is very trendy now so I have
some difficulty to do this this this
chaos but I can say that tree into got
remote jobs in the north of Europe so
two are working locally but basically
that that two local companies are
startups that are based on Germany or in
the Netherlands
in Sweden so I think we can speak of
hundred percent of international
internationalization that's great well
what are some of your goals now you've
gotten a developer job you've you've got
in this community running you've proven
out the notion that people can come into
your community they can learn to code
you will help them build up their skills
helps them build up their network and
that they can get jobs now that you've
proven that and you have this proven
path to help people in your community
get developer jobs what are your goals
for the near future well for the near
future I have to do I have two main
goals one is to become a senior
developer in my team contributing more
for the for the future of the
architecture in the web application but
in a second plan not less important than
the first I want to continue driving and
to motivate people to learn to auto
program on free code camp I will say I'm
a free code camp evangelist because I
really believe in free code camp because
I've tried a lot of other boot camps and
I didn't have success and I think free
code camp F as the the main ingredients
to turn you into a successful programmer
in less than one year yeah so I think
people should try free code camp they
should join they should try the
challenge they they need to speak with
people and to surpass the challenges and
to learn how to program they have
everything every tool they need it's on
their hand the first moment do they sign
up to free code camera all right well
thank you so much Aurora for joining us
my English I'm not a native speaker your
English is excellent
you're great yeah it was nice to see you
are you gonna come run with us tomorrow
of course all right I love fun running
tomorrow yeah awkward Fizbo all right
next Robert have a seat man welcome yeah
so thank you for flying in from Vienna
you lead the free cocaine vienna group
along with Daniel Deutsch who who
couldn't make it
he's a student tell us a little bit
about the origins of free coke camp
Vienna which I think you said is about
three years old now yeah it's like
there's so much to say but it basically
started I now have a developer job and I
mainly attribute that to free coca which
is awesome and when I started as a
student
shortly after there's this there was I
think it still is this is getting
started guide and you're getting courage
to check up your local group there was
no local group but there was a nice
guide saying if there is no local group
start a Facebook group but this is how
you do it so I did and then no one came
so I asked my wife to join I invite her
we were to then like this is probably
just in the span of a couple of days
there was still no more people joining
so I got impatient so I think I texted
you on get her or something
I was like I don't know if Quincy
Larsson will reply to me but he replied
and he was awesome and I was asking can
I start a meetup a comm group because I
knew meetups from my city there's a
quite a bit of them thinking that that's
the way I could get more people involved
because I wanted to meet other students
right and then I did that you replied
like yeah of course sure just keep in
mind it cost money and stuff and I was
like that's fine so that's basically how
it started in the format that we have
now we've been going almost three years
like this I think November or December
and we basically have it where I always
try to say that this is the local group
for free coke and Vienna this is a
meet-up but if anyone wants to help in
any way you know I'm just here now
helping it to grow starting and keep it
going
so we have a format normally now of why
don't you talks and some group coding or
some group discussion whatever people
want to do just to keep a monthly thing
where people can meet other students
which is yeah what I'm doing yeah
awesome and so it sounds like you have a
very supportive wife how has that helped
you because I also benefit from an
incredibly supportive wife Jada I don't
know if you're watching thanks and I
none of the freako camp would be
possible if if Jade hadn't believed in
me and let me take an extended departure
from working full-time so I could so I
could build freako camp and start trying
to try to build up the initial community
so talk a little bit about your
relationship with your wife and how is
she learning to code as well
yeah I think she could benefit from
learning I don't I think she doesn't
know what she's missing out on but yeah
she's been super supportive in the
beginning there maybe we can touch a
little bit on because I used to work a
longer career of all sorts of jobs from
theater station to customer service to
sales to you know selling newspapers on
the phone selling software I was working
actually here in Dublin for two years in
C rocks and I was in Oracle but mainly
support or like phone sales so I was
exposed to technology and I've always
loved computers as a young age but for
some reason I figured programming was
hard and I like I imagined it to be this
really hard thing so long story short
and back to I was starting a agency kind
of company with a with a friend while
working full time so in my spare time
and my wife is so supportive so when she
was watching TV or series I was sitting
on my computer trying to make some
business happen right and I did that
before I learned to code with WordPress
sites and themes and prepaid you know
themes and plugins and stuff and
that led eventually to me being curious
we are doing shared hosting can I do the
hosting myself and we have a better
margin so I debts for the first time I
got exposed to online courses like
treehouse and Linux Academy where I was
realizing it's hard easier than I
thought
to learn these technical skills that I
was interested in but a bit afraid of so
that led to me discovering that oh I
should probably try and do this with
programming as well again and it really
clicked with me but it wasn't until I
really was like oh I can do this I got
the belief that this is not as hard as I
thought but it was mainly be a free code
jam but sort of my base or like my go-to
place for learning that I kind of got
the ball rolling and really got into
learning and through all of this my wife
has been super supportive because as I
said you know like she would do letters
leisure stuff at evening and I would you
know be unsocial doing my stuff which
works but it can only work for that long
kind of you have to find a balance yeah
yeah well I wasn't aware that you had
such a whining career and done so many
different things and it's great that
you've worked here in Dublin so it
sounds what are you originally from
Vienna I'm from Norway I worked here in
Dublin and that's where I met my now
wife she's Austrian so we moved to
Norway we we established a family and
then we moved to Vienna her home city
like five years ago yeah Wow so it
sounds like you all have really
benefited from the EU like ability to
fluidly move between countries because
you've been moving a lot no way he's not
in the EU were in this collaboration
like Switzerland and us and I can't
remember Luxembourg I think but it makes
it basically I can only remember the new
each and one EFTA but it's something
like that
for people who are in the EU Switzerland
ch yeah yeah I think that's what it is
yeah but that's really nice because
basically that and Schengen so that the
passport agreement makes it so it's
really easy to visit anything in Europe
and it's really easy depending on the
country to get like work workers license
or just the extended visa you don't even
have to apply often so that's nice and
yeah so if you're curious about like
working abroad then Europe Europeans
should like more spiit Europeans should
avail of that yeah yeah yeah so now that
you're leading the study group what are
some of your goals for a frico camp
Vienna and for your own personal career
for 2019 I'm I'm really grateful that I
have Donny Deutsch with me he's been I
think about two years my co organizer
and co-host I also run to other meetups
now over a year one is for of UJS and
one is for golang which because I love
this interjection of meeting people
getting to know them help them if I can
and this like makes of people encode
which is awesome so I know that even if
I take a break or slow down
free coke and Vienna it's still gonna be
there because Daniel Deutsch is just
running the show and it's seamlessly is
perfect with the other meetups I'm
slowing down now because I think what I
want to happen in let's say 2019 to put
a number on it or is to switch a little
bit my career from pure developer to
doing more developer relations in one
form or with another my dream future
would be where I get to do
professionally what I do as a hobby you
know
with the meetups so if I can be more you
know conferences traveling online forums
doing community work and that'd be the
focus of my
yeah professional career that's where I
want to navigate towards and but I still
want to do some coding even if it's like
demos or prototyping or preparing
technical charts and stuff like this
yeah awesome well thank you so much for
flying out the Dublin and it's such a
pleasure to finally meet you in person
you and I of course wanted four years so
it's great to finally meet you and go
out on the rooftop and thank yourself be
together yeah we did and I want to thank
you personally like this has been so
awesome the fact that you started free
code camp and one person can start
something that trickles down to now this
huge movement which it is with all these
channels I like it find it so amazing
and inspiring
you're a true inspiration you are thank
you but it would be nothing without the
help of so many amazing contributors
like yourself so thanks again for
everything you're doing to inspire
developers around the world and
especially in Vienna all right thanks
Hey Hey welcome how's he so Eleftheria
am i pronouncing your name correctly
l-lift theater I left there dia le okay
all right well I like your entire name
it's just so cool and distinctive and
yeah freedom
so yeah it's cool like freedom yeah well
atheria thank you so much for flying in
from Greece you are a very prominent
person in the freako camp community
especially recently you've been
live-streaming
a whole lot of videos you've been
creating videos on things like angular
it's it's incredibly helpful tell us a
little about how you got into tech and
how you started deciding to record all
this and share all this knowledge well I
wanted to learn and firstly I wanted to
learn for me and for myself but I knew
that eventually I wanted to find a job
and I wanted to be sure that everything
I know I can also like go to another
person and maybe teach them so I said
okay how can I do that so start coding
in my computer as always and then I'm
going to record this videos and if they
are good then I'm going to upload them
so basically that's how I started I
wanted to pass this knowledge to other
people and make sure that I also know
these things that's great
and I think it takes a lot of courage to
put yourself out there and to record
videos about a topic that you yourself
or are just learning how did you get the
courage to go out there and what was
your thought process like because I
always wanted to get better I thought
that I should start from somewhere I
should really start from somewhere
because if it's only me that's studying
in my own little room then it's not
going to be anything I wanted to pass
this knowledge to everyone else and yes
I'm still learning I don't know
everything in angular but it's something
that I like doing so I'm doing it great
and your videos have been very popular
and we've had so many people who have
asked for more content on angular so
it's perfect that you started creating
these great videos Oh what are some
things that you plan to do
we're 2018 is almost over coming into
the end of 2018 2019 what do you plan to
focus on for the near future in terms of
creating videos creating articles and
teaching other people about technology
plans in my mind as far as angular is
concerns I would like to focus more on
on angular and angular material so I
would like to create some videos based
on angularjs and maybe mix it with
material library
I would really love to do that but other
than that I'm also interested in UX and
UI design so I was also thinking to
contribute and make some videos in UX
and UI design and other than that I also
have like some plants about teaching
maybe JavaScript like volunteering and I
would love to go in some other
conferences that I have in minds and
maybe if I could help them and also pass
some knowledge I would love to do that
it can be quite scary because as you
know and I'm still learning and and I'm
still cutting it but I believe that if
it's something that you love and it's
something you like then you should do it
no matter what you seem to have a very
strong passion for learning and a desire
to improve yourself and expand your
horizons tell us a little bit more about
your background and how you got to be so
adventurous well it's true and very
questioned and I really want to improve
myself so when I was 18 I had to make a
decision and just started something in
my country in Greece you have to give
some final exams and I want you to go
into an engineer school I wasn't that
good and my exams weren't that good so I
didn't really pass but then because my
sister was in this university I got an
opportunity to pass because she was also
there and as soon as I got in I really
liked everything but the problem was
that we only get the basics from back
ends like Java and some PHP and some
basics on fringe and development like
HTML CSS and JavaScript and then I knew
that if I wanted to get a job that
wasn't enough I had to study on my own
and first I found an article on medium
and they suggested free code camp so I
went there and I at first I didn't knew
what free code combos I started to do
the first challenges which was about
HTML and CSS and so I fell in love with
it so I continued building
[Laughter]
because I continued building and I saw
that I could progress and I could learn
stuff and I could to have some the most
important thing was that I could have
some of those projects in my portfolio
so you also get a portfolio and I had
these challenges and it was really
awesome yeah well thank you so much
Ellaria for coming out here from Greece
and thank you for everything you're
doing to encourage people to learn to
code I think a lot of people when they
watch your videos they are not only they
learn a lot but they get really
motivated because you're just such an
enthusiastic person and I think that
really carries through in the videos
all right well are you gonna are you
gonna come out and run with us tomorrow
[Music]
they were here with me so yeah okay Wow
you said your family came here with you
great well what what is something
exciting to do that you plan to do while
you're in here in Dublin well tomorrow
we are planning on go on a tour in
Ireland so not only do Blaine and I'm
really looking forward to it because
maybe I want to ever have a chance to
visit Dublin again or even Arlen
certainly want to go there I like
traveling and exploring so it will be
great opportunity for me to do a light
awesome well we're so excited that you
were able to bring your family with you
and I hope you have an amazing time
exploring Ireland thank you alright I'm
gonna pop eleftherios information up on
the screen I encourage you to follow her
on Twitter and we're gonna get the next
interviewee oh great thank you you're
very fast alright next let's bring them
in the man remain man I am thrilled to
finally hang out with you in person
we've spent my gosh hundreds of hours
oh man McMahon yeah Ben is a prolific
contributor to freak Oh camp I think
I've spent more time pairing with him
than pretty much anybody in the free
cocaine community
gosh let me let me just recount some of
the things you've worked on so you were
you were very heavily involved in the
JavaScript curriculum which pretty much
everybody who's watching this has
probably try it at some point you
created the challenge of matic which was
the tool to make it easier to contribute
challenges which we're not actively
using anymore but it's an inspiration
for what we're building the the
challenge romatic
I think yours was the challenge dramatic
5,000 memories that why is it one
peasant like couscous yeah well I think
this next one's gonna be challenging
Matic 5000 one just round them high
number getting keep increasing it yeah
that way if people will pick there have
been so many iterations to get us to
where it is well tell us a little about
yourself
I'm based here I am currently kind of a
college student detergent my degree is
all work placement so I'm currently a
working man for a year in kernel
development actually which was a
complete payment from JavaScript foot
curl development
okay I like curl like the command lets
you know it's key you really do that
kernel development okay so talk a little
bit about what you're doing with kernel
development and where you're working so
I'm in ERISA and ERISA network state
being the same market at Cisco I'm
juniper in those guys mainly what I'm
working on is your most York revolves
around you're dealing with you know
their Linux boxes but their links boxes
but a lot of network cards which Linux
you know it works fine with it but it's
not you know the first purpose so there
are a few tweaks and changes each you
made and yeah that's kind of my day job
now at the moment and it's very
interesting cuz I'm learning see and
current development and a lot of other
concepts all the same time on the job
which is an interesting a table science
fo for virtual
yeah and so you're doing you you've gone
from doing primarily web development
which is what you're doing with free
cooking to really diving many layers of
abstraction down the spectrum at this
stage yeah and no it was something I got
a choice when I got the internship there
to pick a team when I was gone I need to
pick something that I know nothing about
interesting that's also how I said a
frico campus I tried to help I
distinctly remember helping you at like
2:00 a.m. with writing Jade five years
ago or four years ago now back in the
clouds clouds the streams bring back
closer Suri's well I'm happy to report
that I no longer live in the Bay Area in
a one-bedroom apartment and I actually
have an entire house with little kids
running around it now so I have a spare
bedroom that my in-laws stay and when
they visit and I've I get streamed from
there we should absolutely get on and do
a stream at some point it has to be a
closet though it's not the same it's not
a cloud okay so we do have a closet it's
just very hot and I'm full look at I say
I did my time in the the free cooking
closet now I want to sit in a proper
room free closet cap so what are some
you've been active in the free cooking
community you primarily been focused on
your new job and your your internship
before that which involved probably an
incredible amount of learning are you
are you interested in coming back and
continue to contribute to the free
cocaine community in the near future oh
I'm dying to get back the problem with
working with coding full-time is you
have to do you actually have to live
some degree because these days I'll come
home and I'll be like I don't wanna
write no record I wanna go to bed um but
yeah I'm hoping to find some time to
strike getting back into it it takes I
want to like block off a week or
something to reacquaint myself with the
code base and stuff before I dive back
in because it's definitely changed and
excuse me in the year I sell - on active
yeah well great well
Stuart's actively working on making the
curriculum a lot more accessible
we're Stuart's only a few hours drive
from you if you ever want to pair
program in real life which is kind of a
clean thing that we used to do back in
the day right
so I think we should stop talking about
tech and talk about this wonderful city
that you call home where we're having
this event as far as I know you're the
only person I've talked to tonight who
lives here I've never got a few people
who have lived here for shorter periods
of time but what is Dublin all about if
you had to describe Dublin how would you
describe it it doesn't have to be one
word I didn't impose that restriction
just I'm trying to be concise though as
well like don't in such a strange place
because it's got like you have Google
and then you'll have like a pub next
door with an old man drinking Guinness
in it
it's kind of got like a foot in both of
those worlds and it's very interesting
culturally from that point of view and
it's kind of it's a country that's grown
up pretty fast
and it's become really progressive of
late so it's it's a it's a happening
place for definite and you can't see it
anymore but if you look at the windows
earlier you can see cranes everywhere
there's a huge metal construction a huge
mental development and we're very lucky
as well like you've no shortage of tech
companies around here so for people
definitely in Europe it's a good
destination to kind of pick if you're
looking for somewhere to you know start
a career in tech because there are a lot
of places and they're doing a lot of
hiring at the moment um but other than
that like I like to think the people are
friendly enough referring to me cuz I'm
from here I guess look it's it's
definitely an interesting culture it's
funny when I go to the States
and all the first things I miss is the
people and it's a very different like
interpersonal culture there it's nice
but you do you do mr. to kind of I don't
know everything has to be witty already
has to be sarcastic all that kind of
stuff and it's just it's the funny
little things like that this kind of man
yeah so in Dublin people are constantly
kind of like it's I mean do you think
it's like a city of kind of entertainers
and Joker's kind of learn everybody's
trying to figure out a clever way to put
things well they always kind of portray
the Irish it's not kind of like
quick-witted like smarter type of
character and you know maybe their life
I like to think I'm free all right and
but no like huh you probably shouldn't
and but no yeah like I think there's a
lot of value placed placed on your way
where it's you better win you know I
think it comes across and you meet
people they're normally you know decent
speakers and you know hope for a chat
and don't know a bit tool for a chap but
that's a different story altogether
yeah well what are some things that
aside from kernel development and
hopefully eating back into free cooking
contribution what are some areas of
Technology since you're somebody who is
you know at many different places in the
stack and has a pretty good bird's-eye
view on on how things are moving what
are some things that really excite you
about tech information technology in the
way things are going in terms of new
things
I guess it's a lot of scope for I guess
it's like this is trying to in love with
the tire integration of technology and
people I feel like there's a lot of
issues that are not serious enough that
they need a solution in the past but it
becomes so easy to solve that they will
be a great example is the whole health
technology kind of revolution the way
Evans get that heart rate can't seem out
and all that kind of stuff and there's
been many cases of people probably got
to have afib or atrial fibrillation if
you want the full valuable thing and
because of their SmartWatch it's like
there's an article written about an
Apple watch that alerted the person to
it and it's stuff like that duck and you
know makes huge difference in the lives
because they're you know if you find out
your atrial fibrillation you need to get
it sorted and it's fine
if you sort it and if you don't you get
yourself a lot of trouble so there's all
kinds of applications of health
technology particularly that are not
only really exciting because they're
curled but they're also really exciting
star good they're doing a good thing in
the world that's a really good answer
so are you planning to event I mean do
you want to like 10 years out you're so
young
first of all I think this this guy was
one of the youngest freako camp
contributors how old were you when you
started contributing to freako
what years in the attorney 18 it was
like four years ago almost 16 then yeah
yeah and so you're you're right at the
beginning of your career did you end up
going to university or this year of work
is my third year of college effectively
then I have to go back for more year so
yeah I caught I took the weird right
because I did the self teaching and the
freako camp I'm in the classical
training as well so I've kind of done
all of them in a weird way so knowing
that you know taking you know health
technology and preventive medicine all
that is is an area that there's
tremendous potential for improving
people's quality of life and it could be
you know huge in industry knowing that
and knowing what you know about kernel
development and knowing what you know
about web development what would you say
the the long-term direction you hope to
take your career in at this point yes
actually I'm very happy where I am
I'd say we're a good company to work for
and I thought my work really interesting
I try not to worry too much about the
future the nice thing about tech is that
when you get yourself to a certain
standard you don't have to worry too
much about you know you're not gonna be
unemployed probably for any great period
of time so I I do like a degree of you
know let the river take me wherever and
see what happens for now I definitely
the next five years I could see myself
staying Arista and but I have no plans
even beyond that so I'm looking forward
to seeing what opportunities do present
themselves all right well thank you so
much for joining us here and yeah coming
out and giving us some local flavor yeah
great to talk to you in person in the
flesh hey coming up Matt yeah welcome
Matt tell us a little bit about your
background and what you're doing yeah so
I'm I'm originally a music teacher I
studied music at university talk guitar
on piano for several years and then
which I still do actually just a little
bit in the evenings and weekends but I
realized
it wasn't the career for me I wanted
something which had a bit more direction
had more of a challenge and I met a
friend who I had not seen in a long time
he was studied music with me and he was
like oh I'm a developer now how did how
did that happen and I knew that well I
found a lot of courses online and taught
myself and then a couple years later and
that's incredible and so I started just
looking around different resources and
this was so this was like three and a
half years ago four years ago so I was
started with of course on Coursera EDX
and those kind of things which were
really good because they had he's kind
of deadline so you had to get the core
project in by a certain time and then
people they reviewed them and then
listened to a lot podcasts and I think I
feel it was pretty JavaScript javi you
were on and you were talking about free
code camp for me because code newbie
maybe both and and I heard about Rico
camp and started trying that out and and
realized actually this is this
incredible free platform and yeah just
got really into it and got quite
disciplined about doing it every day and
then and then I heard about these
mutants were going on and which at first
I was am not good enough to go along to
these about everyone's amazing and it
was quite intimidated by it forced
myself to go and then met people who
were very similar to me you know some
people who were above me some people who
weren't quite where I was and and found
that really and suddenly it was oh you
know maybe I can do this and and yeah
it's gone from that really that's
awesome so describe the transition
you're a musician and just looking at
the different steps you would need to
take and planning out your progression
as it became clearer and clearer to you
what you needed to do I think yet to
begin with it's it's fine just to accept
you're not gonna learn everything in one
go I think some people think they maybe
do it for a week and think
I feel like I don't know too much yeah
I'm never going to do this is so this
just it can be overwhelming it's good
just again just do it initially which I
think I did just to try a few things out
and just just enjoy it really not
necessarily I mean I think I need to do
this and me become a developer as soon
as possible
I think it's good to take your time just
to in yeah try to try some things out
and but then as you enjoy it more
hopefully and get a sense that it is
what you want to do trying to find ways
to keep yourself motivated in my case it
was initially doing these courses which
had deadlines at the end of the week and
then in the meetups thinking okay
there's another meetup in two weeks I'd
like to be able to show something to
someone by then you know sometimes you
feel like if you go along and you've not
done anything since last time it's like
you know it's a nice kind of motivator
having some peers around you I think
it's very easy to sort of stay by
yourself and get a bit isolated but you
know what we try and encourage with the
meetups is to get people to come along
and just you know talk to people see
where everyone else is don't feel shy
about it everyone's there to help each
other we're not about you know
criticising I mean might be constructive
criticism but yeah so so your leadership
within within these meetups and and
helping people in your town pick up
these skills what are some observations
you've had about people who've
approached it and how do they generally
find out about the events in comfortable
yeah so we so you had for some more
context I've been going to the meetups
for about two and a half years but I've
only been leading them since the
beginning of this year the person Alex
who was really great
she was running them for a few years but
just had a lot on her plate so she
looked for a volunteer to to carry to
carry on with them and as I was going to
them all the time I thought I should do
that as for observations yeah I mean we
get such a huge range of people that
come there are people who have
surprisingly you get quite a few people
who turn up
and they asked me you know I'd like to
learn to code where do I start and okay
you tried free coke I'm like oh there's
an online platform and they actually
don't realize they've heard seen the
meetups on made me calm or we had the
Facebook group obviously which I
moderate and I'll just like the venue's
have their own websites and stuff so
it's sometimes quite funny word to see
the look on their face when to actually
see something for the first time see the
curriculum and they're like this isn't
all free is it and actually you know you
explained yes it is and so that's great
yeah so we get we do get people who are
really right at the beginning like that
and again this is what I keep telling I
think there's I think we're getting on
for like 6,000 people on the groove but
we get about 20 to 30 people who
actually come and I think there's a lot
of people there and this is probably why
I'm sitting here is too much I'm trying
to make them realize don't be shy
you know we'd love to have you yeah so
we do have that we have a lot of people
who come who are yeah I mean we very
rarely get people who are overly coffee
actually most people are a bit unsure of
themselves and it's nice to sell them
actually know you're doing really well
and yeah and we've had a lot of success
stories lately I think the last mute up
three or four people since the previous
one had got jobs since that one so it's
always nice when people come along and
say hey that's really good
yeah well that's amazing so having 20 or
30 people show up at a meet-up is is
really good I talk to people all the
time who have been working very hard to
build up a kind of a critical mass of
people coming and it takes a lot of work
to get a group to that size it's you
know because it's hard work showing up
at a meet-up and you have to put
yourself out there you have to learn new
things in programming pretty much
everything you do you're doing for the
first time otherwise you just rerun the
script you wrote last time right
so I let's talk about music specifically
and you said you were inspired by your
friend who is musician and how he
transitioned into development and the
parallels you see between music and
coding yeah I think
certainly self-discipline is a key one
like as a kid just getting into the
habit of practicing an hour a day of
guitar and piano in my case and whatever
instrument it may be that's definitely
really been a key one it's being able to
yeah just just motivate yourself try and
sometimes it's sure sometimes it's
really not but but trying to doing a bit
every day even if it is just maybe even
20 minutes is better than leaving long
gaps and then doing a huge amount you
know doing nothing for a month and then
spending a weekend solid it's better to
do yeah a bit every day or every other
day so certainly that kind of thing
other parallels our music our guests
patterns looking for patterns and things
when the chords and scales there's a lot
of this kind of background being quite
interested in music theory and that kind
of picking things apart and seeing how
they work so certainly from that that
translates quite nicely into looking at
code bases and trying to figure out
what's behind the scenes and how that's
happening so yeah what are some of your
near-term goals as far as your
leadership of the the study group and
also just your personal career goals as
far as the study creep yeah trying to
get them get the meet ups more regularly
we are increasing this now we're getting
I've been talking to some more venues
around London and so we're not usually
we're just in the same place but we're
now trying out some other things so
that's helping to keep things keep a bit
more momentum going getting more people
going obviously it's always good and I
try and encourage people on the Facebook
group and our group and people who come
that this doesn't have to be the only
thing go to other meetups or start your
own we're not we don't own the free code
Graham Brand you know we're just
volunteers and so we do get people who
you know well after a session go hey
you're gonna meet up the weekend and do
some coding and stuff so always
constantly trying to encourage that
talking to a few people about maybe
doing some some talks and workshops at
the moment our meetups are quite loose
so which is kind of deliberate because I
want to keep them as unintimidating as
possible so that and also for me
personally when I've been coding all day
to go and have like three hours of
lectures as it were they can be really
great but sometimes you just just want
to talk and enjoy the social aspect so
yeah but that but I think maybe we could
also be a bit more structured to have
occasional talks and that kind of thing
good as far as career I've just started
a new job this week so Wow
congratulations tell us about that so
it's with a company called bulb who are
a green energy company so do 100 percent
renewable electricity and 10 percent
renewable gas so it's quite a good
mission which I'm you know quite
passionate about and they're growing at
a phenomenal rate so they had about
100,000 customers at Christmas and now
it's on to 800 thousand so it's hiring
more developers they want to you know
obviously keep on top of things it was
an interesting first week because it was
everybody whether your senior management
or entry level does the energy
specialist training so learning about
the energy industry and how to deal with
customer interaction so I haven't even
seen the code base yet but we'll see
what it looks like on Monday we're just
gonna be fun but it's unjust nude on the
back end so lots of good stuff that's
great they're working with a
contemporary sex so you'll you'll be
pretty at home because you've been
working with that previously and that's
what you learned yeah yeah my previous
job was mostly react to meetups so quite
familiar with that but then bits of
backend but not too much so it would be
good to have a bit tense to do that as
well I'm doing and it's all in
typescript as well which I'm liking more
and more yeah I'm excited about
typescript too there's a there's a new
version and node that's typescript based
I don't know if you've heard about it's
called demo it's like node but up
backward or I guess an anagram of node
den oh I have the subreddit if anybody's
interested in posting about demo our
demo I'm the administrator on that so
write it now so as you learn more about
typescript especially I'd encourage you
to teach the community about it because
that is a topic that I think everybody
should get some exposure to we're hoping
to add typescript to the free cooking
curriculum as well yep
I mean to be honest I'm pretty much a
beginner in it myself I mean I did you
know the twitch project I did that for
the hell of it I did it in angular2 two
years ago and built that with types well
learned it for that I think it's changed
a bit since then I've mainly been using
flow in my previous job so but I love
the principles of it quite similar so
but it'd be nice so but having said that
it is good to teach things even if
you're not he has an expert because by
teaching you do learn yourself so yeah
maybe that's a good goal I should set
myself is try and teach some people some
typescript at the meetups all right Matt
well thanks again for your leadership of
the frickin cam London group and I
popped your information up on the on the
screen I think are you on Twitter yeah
if anything I'm trying to maybe cut down
social media use a little bit say right
well I would encourage you if you're
visiting London which is one of the most
popular tourist destinations in the
world
or if you happen to be in the area if
you happen to live in in the UK and just
travel there occasionally I would
encourage you to attend one of the
freako camp London events I've heard
great things about it you've got some
amazing photos from your events that
I've seen and and I've heard great
things about the events from various
people have gone likewise when you were
in London please do join us alright well
hopefully within the next year do all
make it out to one of your events I'd
love to go
it's beautiful city it's got so much
history thanks again man
I'm great yeah this is Timo hey team oh
thanks Timo can you tell me how to
pronounce your last name good lunches
good and just good I just t-mobile
inches okay and you're from the
Netherlands yeah
come wait a from the south of the
Netherlands okay so from which city in
the South Netherlands they die beta beta
okay so first of all I just want to make
sure everybody knows Timo is a prolific
contributor I think I was talking about
you earlier when we were going around in
the circle but you contributed an
incredible amount and if you look on the
github repo and look ranked everything
by commits you're way up there along
with Ben McMahon and some of the other
people we've talked to tonight
so Timo you are a young developer who is
rapidly learning new skills and
contributing the open-source talk about
how you got interested in technology I'm
thinking about that recently and the
truth is I don't really know what got me
into this just I found out about it
I tried it and I liked it and I stuck
with it because it seemed fun and yeah I
can't really tell why why I like it but
I like it and I think I like solving the
puzzle I specifically like helping other
people with the things I can help them
with but yeah why why programming I I
don't know it's just it seemed fun and
it turned out to be fun so I'd stick
with it what are some of the ways that
you've contributed to the free cooking
of community over the past year and a
half or so so when it started out as
almost exactly two years ago now and I
started with making small changes to
mostly to the curriculum small fixes to
the tests mostly so there was a test
that was missing correct
Solutions I was allowing solutions that
shouldn't be allowed I try to fix those
and that's mostly what I started out
doing and then I found out about the
free guide being developed and actually
had quite a bit of time at the time that
it was the next development and I got
involved and I spent a lot of time on
contributing to the figure I came by to
the bathroom not the articles the
concert but to the platform the site
around it yeah and the guides
specifically what are some of the
articles that you wrote that you're
particularly proud of I the only article
or the only content on the guy that I
wrote is the on page which I'm still I'm
carry practice I'm sure a lot of people
have seen it and it's actually in the
past year or so it hasn't changed at all
said it's kind of fun but I haven't read
any other in any other content for the
guidance the only constant I've written
so most of your contributions have been
to the application itself and yeah
exactly yeah
I've done a lot too just for the look
satisfied for the performance I could it
in half at one point there was a weird
issue that made the perform the loading
time twice as long as it could be so
that's a fun thing I did and also stuff
around that making the tests better
making it making sure it wouldn't get
better errors when the things failed and
that's sort of what I did around the Chi
yeah so next month we're having the free
coke amp jam stack hackathon we're gonna
be building a lot of applications using
tools like gasps PJs which is what the
guide is built on are you do you have
any time or energy to participate in
that hackathon I think I heard about it
I'm gonna check my calendar I think I
know that was I don't remember but I
think it was something that made it so
that it was difficult for me to attend
but yeah I'd like to know definitely
check again with ok well we moved it
back a week so now it's November 3rd
November 3rd and 4th and even though
we're having an in-person in San
Francisco at github
we're also going to have a much larger
online hackathon and one of the things
we're doing
he's we're building kind of like
Google's lighthouse score you know how
you can you can add like a Chrome
extension we want to do is we want to
build something like Google's lighthouse
score that checks whenever a page is
like redeployed through now if I we
create some sort of web hook and then we
can go in and we can just run a bunch of
tests against it and figure out you know
performance how it's doing performance
wise how it's doing SEO wise
accessibility wise and and other like
basic security considerations things
like that so if you're interested you're
somebody who has a ton of experience
working with the stackin and me and
Stuart are gonna be working on this
basically all through the month of
October during Oktoberfest putting this
tool together to to basically test
hackathon projects programmatically
would that be something you might be
interested in contributing to yeah I
think that definitely sounds exactly
like the kind of thing I'm looking to
contributor right now that is really
guilty about I've been away from the
contributing to if we gotta go for a
while now and it sounds like right up my
alley so yeah I definitely am very good
to look at what I can do would we do
that yeah great well we'll plan to
include you in some of the meetings the
Seward and I have right now we're
focused of course on getting the free
cooking up repo easier to contribute to
in preparation practice over fest got
like a week left
but that I'll definitely loop you in cuz
we would totally welcome your help with
that you've got so much knowledge about
performance and and security and things
like that
what are currently what are you doing as
a developer and what's your what's the
next year and a half or so of your life
looks like wow that's a difficult
question so right now I look at a very
small local software company we're the
only developers are me my boss
a freelance software developer but it's
having a lot of fun they're the people
that are great so that's from the tech
is quite old but also because it's such
a small company I get to do a lot of
different things and I quite enjoyed it
so I I'll be looking into progressive
web apps and will probably be turning
our application to progressive web apps
I'm quite excited to do that and we have
a lot of UI improvements and performance
improvement so I really like those areas
and also happen to be the areas that we
are going to focus on in our application
at my job so works that great awesome
well Timo it's been so wonderful having
you flying in from the Netherlands
hanging out with both what are some
things you plan to do while you're here
in Dublin I'm usually kind of person
that really plans out in advance what I
pretend she likes to do but for this I
didn't look at anything at all so
leaving Monday so I've the older
tomorrow here so I'll probably be at the
thunderin and don't have any idea when
I'm going to do tomorrow apart from that
but hoping to see do some sightseeing in
Dublin tomorrow and that's about it
really yeah well thank you so much for
joining us Timo it's great to meet you
in person
of course and we chemo random twists at
the airport actually and we were you
just saw the free cookie I'm sure he's
like hey Timo and so yeah it was pretty
dramatic sudden meeting and you came
back hung out at the air B&B with us so
yeah we're excited I'm looking forward
to running around the park with you
tomorrow yeah Cheers
yeah hey Sam Sam Williams welcome
likewise have a seat just very quickly
we've got 36 minutes left in the venue
so we're gonna try to get some more
interviews yeah well thanks for all your
articles so far Sam they've been they've
been great and very well received by the
community yeah thank you like the first
article I wrote I was I wrote it just
because I was in China and I hated the
great Great Firewall of China and I sent
it to you and said can you have a look
and you said you loved it and actually
made me an author on the on the free
code camp medium ask on the medium
publication and that just gave me the
boost I needed every other ask or before
that like five ten maybe fifteen viewers
getting on the free code camp things
boosted me and gave me the confidence to
write more and that was really big for
me
right on well you see you're somebody
who's traveled extensively and it seems
like you're constantly learning new
things and kind of pushing the bounds of
your comfort zone you talked about how
you came to be like what what inspired
you to travel and to learn all these new
technologies well I'm an obsessive rock
climber and that's what got me into
traveling and that's what actually got
me into software development I worked as
an aerospace engineer and I realized
that it wasn't what I wanted to do it's
what I wanted to do was do more
traveling and I realized that doing that
doing engineering as a career wasn't
gonna get me there and software
development would so I actually used
free code camp to teach myself how to do
that and after a couple of months of
really hard work I managed to get my
first software job after that I decided
to save up all of my money and go
traveling and then after that I was like
okay I need to take it to the next level
so I spent six months traveling and
learning all the newest things I learned
I taught myself react through yourselves
free code camp and a couple of other
resources I pushed my node skills and I
did everything I could and I wrote a lot
of articles whilst
traveling about what it was like to go
from I know a bit of HTML and a bit of
CSS to I want to become a really serious
developer and that's a drusy transition
that I found quite tricky but hopefully
through those articles have helped some
other people like find their pathway
from very junior developer through to
like a mid-level developer and it's cool
because like some of the articles have
had comment saying this has really
helped this is like giving me a pathway
and that's it's just such a good thing
to see that other people are making that
transition with us so I have to ask is a
rock climber
you know I've enjoyed climbing and enjoy
bouldering I am not good at it at all
but that is a very itinerant lifestyle
you're traveling around from climbing
location to climbing location probably a
lot of national parks and places like
that that you you do outdoor climbing as
well yeah so I grew up doing indoor
competition climbing which was good fun
but I realized that when I started going
outdoors that was the beauty and scenery
outdoors and just climbing on real rock
is so much better than climbing indoors
so yeah I've been traveling around Spain
Germany France Europe having across the
Canada I've been to North Africa and
then this was five months of traveling
around Asia so like months in China
Thailand Lao Vietnam and it's just
brilliant fun traveling and the great
thing is with traveling and doing
software development is that you can
take your laptop with you which means
you can do work whilst you're traveling
I met five or six or the developers
whilst I was travelling who had their
laptop with them and on their rest days
would take the laptop out find a quiet
corner and would do a day's work and
that's how they sustained themselves on
their
perpetual travels which is a really I
think long term is something I
definitely intend to do so when I was
well I spent about five years in China
myself when I was younger like right
after college I moved there and I I
taught and I was a school director and I
did an intensive Mandarin program and
and did an MBA but while I was there I
definitely enjoyed it and I thought
about just living in different countries
for the rest of my life ultimately I
kind of settled in the States and I
still go back to China like I'm getting
ready to move there for like six months
or so just just to live with the family
and give my kids some more exposure to
the language but there was this amazing
book I read I wanted to see if you had
heard of it it was really inspiring to
me at the time it's called vagabonding
by ralph pots
Roth pots I've never had a book no I
think it was kind of a precursor to the
digital nomad movement and I'm not sure
you know whether it holds up and whether
the advice and they're still like best
practices and stuff but it definitely
opened my eyes to it and now there's
this entire digital nomad movement do
you identify as a digital nomad and are
you parts of it a part of any of those
communities currently I'm not a digital
nomad I have a full-time job in
Manchester and I love it and it's
brilliant but in the future I can
definitely imagine myself
well my aim in the future is to get to
the point where I can comfortably
sustain myself in a perpetual travel so
I can go around I can live in a city I
could live in like I could live in
Barcelona for a couple of months and
then I could move to China and then I
could move to Chile and I die is the
goal to have a digital nomad life where
I can work where I want when I want and
have complete autonomy of my life
outside of like the the constrictions of
a traditional job system
in Manchester do you are you able to
work remotely at all or generally just
working in office currently I work in an
office when I started this job I started
as what I thought was a low to medium
level developer I very quickly got
pushed into being a mid to senior level
developer making quite big architectural
decisions which turns out I really
enjoyed so we've got a really small team
and we tend to work all in the office if
I want to work at home for a day if I
need to I can that's fine but at the
moment with the size of the company I
work out working at an office especially
because it's a 10-minute commute it's
not two hours of driving I find it's
quite nice to get away from home because
that means that when you finish you go
home and you can shut off yes
occasionally you do have to pop
occasionally do you have to pop online
because there's a bug on the live system
but you can go back but most of the time
it's you finish work at the end of the
day you go home and being able to fully
disconnect being is something I'm
actually surprisingly enjoying compared
to when I've done a little bit of remote
work before well you came from I think
you said aerospace engineering yes so
that's a field that's another
engineering field you know software
engineering software development also
applies a lot of similar you know math
and kind of engineering principles how
much of your aerospace engineering
training has been helpful in moving into
software development I think actually
quite a lot of it a lot of the problem
solving and the ways that you approach
technical problems that we were taught
and we practiced through University
we're actually really applicable to
software development unfortunately
they're not actually that
lickable to real-world engineer like
aerospace engineering which is ironic so
I think a lot of the skills the
problem-solving and know the approaches
and like how to deal with something when
you hit that wall that's the kind of
thing that you deal with quite a lot at
university when you hit a project and
you hit that wall how to break through
that wall whether it's taking some time
off or approaching it from completely
different direction
yeah Aris like aerospace engineering
taught me more about software
development than engineering what would
be some advice that you would have for
other people who have gone into a field
of engineering whether it's mechanical
engineering or aerospace engineering or
petroleum engineering or or a field
where perhaps growing a lot less quickly
than software development is which I
think is probably the fastest growing
field maybe on earth uh-huh what would
be your advice to those people who
already have kind of a traditional
engineering training but are interested
in pivoting into software development if
you're interested in pivoting into
software at all give it a try
stuff like free code camp and there's
hundreds of other free resources out
there they're all absolutely brilliant I
learn most of the stuff I know now
through free code camp it's free it has
step-by-step tutorials that give you
really good feedback as you're
progressing through and the worst that
happens is you try it out you do two or
three months and you find that you don't
enjoy it that much that's two or three
months you've learned some new skills
but you don't progress if you do enjoy
it and you end up moving into software
you can end up as a remote developer you
could end up traveling around the world
you can end up working with chatbots
like I currently do and working with
someone's like the coolest tech like
working with AI working with machine
learning and doing something that is so
beyond what you are constricted to
within the traditional engineering roles
thanks so much for coming out from
Manchester and are you gonna you're an
athletic guy are you gonna come
with us run tomorrow unfortunately I've
got a flight quite early tomorrow
morning which I'm hoping that I'll be
sober enough to fly on well it's gonna
be yeah so unfortunate not gonna make
the run
no worries well we'll have fun where I
think we're gonna go and do like a
little pub crawl out for this so yeah
we've got some we've got Ben the local
here and he's gonna guide us around town
so yeah it'll be cool to hanging with
you later tonight thanks again for
coming up man it's great
great to finally meet you in person
cheers Sam all right
Richard have a seat and okay great
all right awesome we're making good
progress so Richard I'm so thrilled
we've talked so many times we've been in
touch Richard is in charge of free coke
amp leads free coke camp Oslo and the
free coke Hume Instagram which has I
don't know 10,000 ish yeah and it's it's
great photos of free coke amp events and
just beautiful workstations and code
setups and things like that
all the good stuff yeah what are your
goals so you really took charge on the
Instagram and I mean you owned it for
you were already very prolific on
Instagram you had a lot of your own
photos you had a ton of followers
yourself and you really took the free
cocaine Instagram which was largely just
chillin there cuz I think I was the only
person who had access to it at the time
and and and now it's it's played vibrant
and there's a lot of beautiful photos on
there can you describe that process of
thinking like hey maybe I could help out
with this and and how you went about it
yes so I think people took you from
about 3000 at a time are you saying it
was like underutilized upping the fan
thank you
very very very good on Twitter and
things like that that stuff was doing it
what I was doing on my old Instagram was
just pictures of my code stuff I'm
working on and things like that so we
had the conversation about doing some
stuff with the free code can point to it
have a lot more of the community staff
in there as well trying to re reupload
over people's pictures regram them or
they color so that's kind of what we try
to do get the community thing more in
there and just try and try and build
that up and have a bit more of a
community little bit more so other
people could get involved in that as
well so that was the plan yeah
yeah and early on you you made it a
clear point that people could basically
add mention freako camper hashtag free
code camp on Instagram and we get
basically signal boost their photos and
and of course credit them and everything
our people still doing that pretty
regularly we need them to do it more do
it more especially to do with if there's
meetups going on
that stuff's great so if we've got a
meet-up and you've got picture of all
the groups and stuff like that we love
that stuff so like send those stuff yeah
I'm constantly going in there checking
hashtags or if you've been tagging as in
them down as well trying to find the
good stuff out there and posting it I'm
there so if if people send me the good
stuff then it means I don't have to do
anything so what we want to do yeah so
beyond the Instagram you have been
leading these two study groups in two
very different cities you're originally
from Leeds but you live in Oslo as well
yes so my kind of journey was the whole
code thing started I was living in Oslo
so I kind of got background to it
coding had done a little bit when I was
very young HTML with inline CSS so we're
talking about 1997 here so I got back
round 2 and I was actually living in
Oslo at a time
then end up taking over the admin of the
Oslo group because the person who was
running it wasn't really running it so
they had a backlog of people they wanted
to get into the group but they weren't
being accepted so I should get hold of
the the admin our time and and get her
to add me then I took over the admin of
that and as I was going back to Leeds so
I kind of been in Oslo twice basically
I've gone back to Leeds we had Merrick
who tented in the New York show and he
was really like I want to do it
it's gonna give me a kick up the ass if
if I have this commitment that I'm the
person here okay I'm back in lead so I
went over to Leeds got involved in the
Leeds community I think at that time
they just added some more admins to kind
of get stuff moving a little bit seen
also when I was there we start doing the
coffee and code meetups you know it
started weekly I mean doing once a month
and trying to find it's free which was
great with Mike took over that he made
it once a week and that momentum was
really good so back in Leeds we had the
first copying code Meetup
I think after I've been there month then
they had me as the admin there so we
started trying to do more frequent
coffee and code stuff there so we're
doing it monthly there as well and
obviously we've got Johnny Bissell
famous The Legend of Johnny Bissell well
legend so if you want to just message
Johnny breeze on Twitter and you say
indeed you know I think Johnny biz I'm
gonna show is just say you a legend and
we've got Charlie as well a few of the
guys who are helping him lead so we got
a coughing coach one in there and I
think I think that's the good thing
about the Facebook groups is you look at
all the different cities around the
world and there's some groups that are
slow and some groups that really go in
somewhere any it doesn't it doesn't
start it doesn't start in the groups it
starts outside the groups when you can
start making that community outside the
group
Danny translates to stop happening the
group so I said I went back to Leeds and
we started doing stuff in Leeds they
moved back to Oslo again and Mark did a
great job of making copying code me ups
every week from then you know I've been
I've been back in Oslo maybe six months
now I think if you lie down and work it
in between 7 and 13 people every single
Monday night
always in the big city it's like 800,000
people so we've got 400 people in the
group I think something like that so to
have that community of people coming
every single every single week it's
great because it's the motivation to
keep going you know even if all we do is
just talk rubbish all night and we don't
code anything which happens like that
for me it happens the majority of times
it's made before Monday night it's my
favorite night a week I get to go hang
out with these guys and we chill you
know we'll go down to the lake and we'll
have some beers by the lake
we'll go out and have a party it's gone
beyond we're here to learn to code it's
like good friendships and I think with
what we're doing also especially there's
a very big immigrant population they're
like eh
so it's nice to have something that ties
us together and brings people together
that as a social thing as well you know
England Norway America
oh and Czech Republic got lots of people
that automatic have disconnection with
you because your code but also you
brings together gives you a good bond
which is really cool it's like it's
bigger than the sum of its parts
yeah so you you just to summarize some
of the insights you've shared first of
all trying to build a community with
like friends and a city first and get
coffee and codes going and then try to
invite the local Facebook group into
that rather than trying to post on the
Facebook group hey I'm trying to have
this event if you get a critical mass
going first for you people meeting it
makes it easier to bring more people
from the community is that kind of what
you're saying no I'd say the way we
worked it was this I'm gonna go study
every Monday I don't care if you come
I'm going like this is my thing and for
me that's who it's one of those things
where I had to do it and I'm motivating
myself to go do it and when that when
that momentum keeps going you might have
one person one week may have no person
as a week after but it's it's you're not
doing it because of how many people are
coming you're doing it because that's
what you have to do and I think when you
have these groups where people have got
good leaders there and they're just
gonna go do it because that's what
they're gonna do and it happens like
even in the Facebook groups if you're
not if you're not posting as a leader as
a leader if you're on a posting and
you've got be the one who's doing it
even if nobody else is required it's
almost one of those things like you're
so selfishly blinkered like
you almost explain you don't even care
what's going on your you've got to do it
people might not be replying to keep
posting keep posting that I call you bed
it's like and eventually the momentum
are calm you know leads are so similar
to also with the amount people six or
seven hundred thousand right so if if
those groups can do in your in a city of
ten million people you've got you've got
such a base then even we had and the
only thing those differences the fact
that we went I'm gonna do it and just do
it don't care if you get any response so
yeah just go do it for yourself keep
posting make sure make the event for the
coffee and Co me up wherever it is and
it's like was it Field of Dreams what's
the movie where it's like building and
they'll come exactly our build and
they'll go me and I have to say just a
quick observation because we're running
out of time we're gonna do a big group
photo but I have to say that the study
groups like where a study group will
become huge and vibrant and help tons of
people get a job has very little to
correlation with the size of the
metropolitan area has everything to do
with the leadership of that study group
and how passionate they are and how
willing they are to do exactly what you
said like I don't care if you come I'm
gonna be there so come and code with me
if you want but either way I'm gonna be
there you know rain or shine and that
attitude makes all the difference so
thanks so much for parting that in both
the Oslo and and in the leads groups and
I'm hopeful that we can take a lot of
your wisdom and you can write some
articles and we can use that to help
more people create these successful
groups thanks so much for everything
you're doing Richard alright
okay we're here with unded I do you have
his name up on the screen okay perfect
and Allah has contributed extensively to
freako camp through the free cooking of
guide and also publishing articles on
medium tell us a little bit about
yourself and how you discovered freako
camp and decided to contribute to it
okay at the moment I'm a student
actually just started like last week
University my journey with free code
camp started when I moved from like Qi
sharp to JavaScript because I needed to
learn OGS for like a server application
and I basically discovered frequent time
to learn JavaScript then I started like
reading the articles on the medium
publication and when I decided that I
wanted to also write articles it just
felt natural to go to publish the
articles on the media publication and
then from there like the involvement
with the community just like grew
gradually leading to contribute also
mainly to the guides repository but also
like to the other repositories like
smaller contributions awesome well thank
you for your many contributions so far
what are some areas like when you look
at the free cocaine community Andhra
what are some areas where you see
potential for improvement that you're
interested in diving into oh okay I
think that the backend curricula is like
very good on the beginner level but
there are like so many topics that could
be covered of course like the do you
work on actually developing the courses
is like enormous for example a
technology that I'm very interested in
is graph QL I think that will be a very
nice addiction you are also using that
internally in for the who indicates
repository we've got to be so very cool
technology would like like to see that
yeah well I will tell you under the if
you're interested in helping contribute
to that that's like we want to add type
strips and we want to add graph girl
those are the two things that we're most
excited about adding to the curriculum
of course we have other like things kind
of supplementary things but we want both
graphical and and type scripts to be
covered in the core curriculum so yes we
would welcome your help and and you're
right there absolutely
we basically scratched the surface on
testing on security on a lot of these
major NPM modules that people can add
that add so much functionality and we'd
love to cover a lot more would you be
interested in helping with that yeah
okay I'm sure there is I have a graph to
our article in writing should be
published life ready couple weeks as
helping the curricula I can do some work
the whole like not too much involvement
because of like the plenty of things I
have to do in this period starting
University having like a startup in the
launching side job really heavy on the
schedule but like the article is a good
start I think you said you just started
school
you just university yeah how old are you
18
oh wow you're getting really into really
deep into technology pretty young that's
it that's excellent yeah I actually like
started my first experiences with coding
like a 12
the story goes basically oh I like games
why not make one and then like I just
started with the software that lets you
just create the game with drag-and-drop
stuff and then you say oh I want what
these like cool feature I will run some
scripting and then or programming super
cool
I want this yeah have you so are you
thinking you like game maker tools like
that what did you use early on for
building games okay yeah I already want
to use game maker
we actually had an issue because we are
tree people using game maker but we chew
different versions of a game maker and
we didn't know that and so like at the
time of course we didn't used it I
didn't even know that get existed and so
like sending the versions and loading
them into the software like broke the
code and we are like these two weeks in
which we were like building this very
basic AI and every time we like sent
each other the code it broke and we
realize oh you're using eight point one
i'm using eight points oh wow that's
kind of doesn't sound like they have
very good backward compatibility all
right have you looked at unity 3d or the
Unreal Engine or any of the more
contemporary big developer tools for
game development
I did something unity but actually in
the last three years I haven't done like
anything in game development I've been
doing mostly back-end work like on an
IOT framework some front-end work with
react for the interface well but you
know IOT related stuff is of course very
interesting interesting in nodejs is
powerful tool for doing IOT stuff so if
if you want to write more about that
we'd welcome that if you do want to dive
in and do more game development there we
published a lot of videos on game
development like build flappy bird build
you know basic kind of almost
programming one-on-one type classes like
tic-tac-toe and stuff but we would
welcome more in-depth game development
it sound especially because it sounds
like something that you were passionate
about the guy you in a coding them in
the first place yeah I definitely want
to get back to game development in the
future but not in the short future of
like when from the IOT framework that
I'm building at the moment is like
version 1 ready then we can start to
think about ok let's begin another big
project until then
game development takes really all the
time so it's honest stop well it's it's
great to hear about your projects and
I'm glad you are staying focused on your
IOT stuff keep us posted and keep
writing your articles are helping a lot
of people thank you vouch all right
Cheers
all right so Matt's over here we're
gonna take a big group photo and then
we're gonna gracefully leave okay great
hey everybody hey we're gonna take a
very quick group photo and then we're
going to follow the leaving guidelines
and make sure that we leave the place in
a good condition oh yeah everybody come
over here and I mean this wall is so
colorful I love the but we can get maybe
the window in the wall in the shot
unless somebody has an even better place
to treat it all right
all right we're gonna take a group photo
okay to all our people in the back I'm
medium people in the middle I think yeah
yeah we have a camper who's in the
bathroom all right well everybody thank
you so much for tuning in for the stream
we got to talk to a lot of exciting
people doing exciting work both within
the free cocaine community and just
working as developers so I hope you all
have a beautiful evening we're gonna
chop all this up into a great highlight
video that we'll post if you missed any
of it you can catch the highlight video
and from Dublin signing off have a
beautiful day